what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to some
more kevin samuels
they seem to be doing like pretty well
on this account like you guys seem to
like them
um they depressed me a little bit some
days i'm not even gonna lie to you
but you know i can deal with stuff
anyways before i start let me know in
the comments if you agree with kevin
samuels or you disagree
if you disagree let me know what points
you think he is wrong on
and what video i should react to next
also i'm trying to get to 15 000
subscribers so
like if you guys want to help me with
that if you like the channel
feel free okay modern women have a
choice to make
58 minutes oh no
50 why did they is this the future
two hours oh my god
let me play all sort by
most popular
wait 10 ways to increase your eggplant
oh my god i got this to naturally help
you enlarge the size of your penis
this cannot be real stop
this can't be real okay welcome back for
those of you don't know my name is kevin
samuels i'm a professional menswear
stylist and my job is to make sure that
each one of you looks good
smells great and is your best each and
every day if you like these kind of
videos go ahead and subscribe to this
channel and turn on notifications for
our future video and live stream updates
hit that bell okay guys let's have some
fun
look we all know the world isn't fair
guys ask this question all the time to
women the science count
you know i know the entire world knows
it
does now like i said the world isn't
fair and that's the truth that a lot of
i don't want to comment like i don't
really think that it does
guys don't want to deal with now there
are all kinds of pills and creams
lotions and potions out there being
marketed to guys
each and every day trying to help you
increase the size of your
penis but who do you trust who do you
believe there are some foods that have
been shown to help naturally
increase the size of your penis now i'm
not here to tell you it's going to work
but rather point you in the right
direction come on be real most guys
would like to have larger junk
and if there's a plastic surgery or some
kind of procedure out there
kind of like boob job the average guy
will be lining up
we would take an extra job to do what we
had to do
in order to get that done i feel so
uncomfortable
i feel so uncomfortable on second
thought maybe there's a good thing that
we don't have there because
you know some guys would just go
overboard now regardless if the weather
you fit in that category or you're in
the category where you love what you
have
here's some food for thought let's get
started
number one coffee wait a minute yes
coffee has caffeine
and it's also a vasodilator but there
have been studies this show
their coffee rubs actually help increase
blood flow down there i'm not going to
go into a specific description on each
one of these
rather tell you that whether they're
taken internally or used
externally these foods have been shown
to work to varying degrees with guys
your mileage may vary next up
onions onions onions onions
i'm just imagining guys like running to
the grocery store
like eating onions they may be bad for
your breath but they're really good for
your body
not only do can they potentially help
your junk they've also been shown to
help tamp down
and lower blood pressure hey they're
also really tasty
just make sure you got your breath mint
nearby
next up oysters if you've ever eaten
oysters
you know they're a natural aphrodisiac
i'm really trying to think about it
oysters are fire i'm not even gonna lie
i've only had them a couple times but
fire
how desperate you must have had to be
for a man to eat the first oyster well i
digress
oysters have shown to have aphrodisiac
like properties and if they can give you
two to three inches down there hey you
can handle business when you get there
next up
oh god the other white meat pork
hey that's don't kill the messenger but
hey there's studies out that have been
shown that
pork actually can help some guys gain
and when i talk about games studies are
talked about anywhere from
one to three inches plus another inch in
girth
any size increase is a better in size
and by the way
if god i feel so uncomfortable oh i
don't like this i feel so uncomfortable
if it doesn't work you can always eat
and use these things so let's keep it
rolling
nuts and seeds kind of like juices and
berries yes
nuts and seeds a great form of protein
they help to round out a balanced diet
they give you
good cholesterol good fats and hey maybe
they'll also help
fatten you up down there next we have
porridge
yeah porridge like the three little
bears in porridge porridge
look maybe there's a good reason why
medieval man ate poor july
those long cold nights there wasn't
electricity a nice bowl of porridge
mama bear may have had a good night
another superfood
bananas good source of potassium great
for people who work out if you're a
cyclist you're a runner
you know banana is it weird that this
video is making me hungry
oh my god and us have great restorative
properties
maybe they help restore you down there
you saying vote
a lot of bananas he's the fastest man in
history
maybe you can become one of the biggest
men in history bananas
god i feel so uncomfortable i feel so
uncomfortable may be a fit for you
we gotta go ahead and with the sexual
innuendo if we got a banana we need a
cherry nothing like a little cherry on
top or a cherry down below and if you
want to do something with her cherry
cherries may help you with your banana
to make a nice split whoa i came up with
that off the top of the head the boy is
good but either way cherries
may just get you where you need to be
why is this making me feel so
uncomfortable
like the inuit like this isn't funny i'm
not i guess it's kind of it's
funny because it's so cringy check it
out let's round out the fruits with
nectarines
no not apricots not tangerines not
oranges
not peaches but nectarines hey it's the
summertime nectarines are great
you can use it with whipped cream
actually you can make a nice little
aphrodisiac thing for your girl with
these fruits and some whipped cream eat
you some nectarines after you start out
with some oysters hey
good morning her maybe it works for you
let me know because i like nectarines on
their own if they have a side benefit
even better last but not least
my favorite fish salmon salmon salmon
salmon it's
i love salmon salmon's fire good is
sushi
shimmy it's good grilled it's good so
many different ways and if it helps you
actually increase the size of big island
and twins
it's better for everybody all around
look guys
this is a fun video not meant to be
taken seriously look
bottom line is you're boring what you're
born with learn how to use it
there are seven billion people on the
planet everyone's junk apparently works
some just may have a little bit more
than others but you know as i do
all guys feel a little bit more
confident when things are together down
there
luckily some of us are rocking what we
want some of us may need a little bit
more than we have
either way take this video and rock with
it do us a favor hit us up in the
comments
i really don't think that girls will
jump you based on like
you'd have to have it pretty bad for a
girl to dump you based on that
um you know this was another hahaha
feel good video that i just love
watching let me know in the comments
what i should
react to next time
and if you guys don't subscribe after
that video after you put me through that
look i'm just i'm just playing subscribe
if you want bye guys